in Georgia radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene is
now being asked by the feds to account
for a 3.5 million dollars in political
donations made to her that she has not
itemized this is very very important a
Newsweek article says the Federal
Election Commission the FEC has asked
Marjorie Taylor green for more
information about three and a half
million dollars in contributions to her
re-election campaign
in two filings posted to the FEC website
Monday and surfaced on Twitter by
Georgia public broadcasting reporter
Stephen Fowler on Tuesday the
congresswoman's husband Perry green who
is also her treasurer draining the swamp
right was asked to provide additional
details about donations the campaign
received during the first two quarters
of 2021. look at these numbers
between January and March the green
campaign received 2.5 million in un
itemized donations from undisclosed
donors while the campaign received
another nearly million dollars in un
itemized donations between April and
June the campaign reported a total of
more than four and a half million
dollars in donations during the same
period candidates are not look at this
candidates are not legally obliged to
itemize donations or disclose the
identity of donors for contributions
that total under two hundred dollars for
an election cycle for donations that do
need to be itemized campaigns must
Supply details including name of the
donor address occupation employer and
the date of the donation the FEC has
given the green campaign until October
12 to provide clarification about the
three and a half million to comply with
FEC rules the campaign must either
provide information about the donors or
show the money came from small donors
only from at least seventeen thousand
six hundred and thirty individuals
contributing no more than
199.99 each
um it is conceivable mathematically that
this was only through small donations
but it is not particularly likely so she
pretended to be about draining the swamp
and yet she is the swamp un itemized
donations husband is campaign Treasurer
anybody sick of hearing about these
stories and the nothing ever actually
ends up happening like everything these
people do
everything these people do yes is a
grift I'm still wondering how did she
get away with declaring two Homestead
exemptions at the same time on her taxes
do you even remember that story that was
was it six months ago was it 12 months
ago you're only allowed to have one
homestead exemption or Declaration uh
Marjorie Taylor green had two
and we discovered that it was being
investigated I've heard nothing since
what's going on with that could this be
as simple as Marjorie Taylor green just
as using her campaign donations as a
personal slush fund and used it for
personal expenses could it be that
simple
hopefully we'll find out more and she
has until October 12th to disclose the
oranges or the origins per your
preference and usage of those donations
we will try to follow it unfortunately
too often the story goes nowhere and we
never hear about it again I will be
covering these stories as well as
updates to other stories from earlier
this week on the David packman Show
Instagram make sure you're following us
there at davidpackman show and follow me
at david.pakman